hello there my name is Ryan right say
your name I want to do it right the show
all the time
salamander Sally that's not too bad for
a female voice we're gonna check out a
video titled disturbing dr. Phil
disturbing doctor from the serving slash
dr. Phil interviews teen convicted of
murdering his mother with a sledgehammer
I've never wanted a murder my mom but I
have wanted a murder several mom's
before and a sledgehammer is a clever
way to go this is not a joking matter
people I wanted to murder my stepmom
everyone do with it well we will one day
I regret it this real-life horrible
matricide incident is something worth
joking about let's do this I love the
show did you kill your mother yeah you
killed your mother and why did you kill
her she want something taking care of my
family meaning you and your brother
sound like a deal
is that who you mean and so because she
wasn't taking care of you and your
family you decided to kill her did you
think about discussing it with her
instead of killing her I didn't think it
wouldn't do anything you thought well
doing good to talk to her so I'll just
kill her when did you decide to kill
your mother I decided to died and the
method you chose Wow
was what beating her to death and you
beat her to death with one sledgehammer
oh and how many times did you hit her
with the sledgehammer
I don't remember about it either once or
she hit her
10 times or 100 times cut shy about 20
times was this a three pound
sledgehammer five pound sledgehammer die
down nothing heavy yeah way bigger than
a hammer right mm-hmm yeah and where did
you hit her in her where was she when
you did this she was in her what was she
doing she is her slave okay so your
mother was asleep in her room kind of
glad a video got cut short yeah that's
it oh man I mean I once worked on a I
once wrote my own story that dealt with
like someone who murdered his own mother
but I was never fortunate enough to
catch an interview of someone who
actually did yeah that was creepy that
was incredibly disturbing like just the
way he talked his mannerisms this it's a
literal demon inside of him Louie's
voice yet whenever he would ask a really
like deep question he instead of
answering you just go yeah he had this
like God that's the type of this stuff
to like that's how like actors for a
serial killers yeah they have like weird
mannerisms there are certain things it's
all con Rico I never want to be afraid
of my son but I feel like she was
probably afraid of him he's probably
that quiet kid well this dude has like
some very evident thing of mental
illness there's like this strange
disconnect it has to be some type of
serious mental illness like laugh to win
when he was like Oh much bigger than a
hammer he like laughed that is not okay
yeah that that you are not sane yeah you
know like matricide is something that
does have it's a real thing and to see a
person who does it it's it's scary
because like there's this like weird
part of you that like can not understand
the action but understand the person a
little bit but at the same time it's
like you're
no this is not a good person to be
around
like he like could have done this to a
stuffed animal I mean he would have the
same feelings like from like hitting his
stuffed animal to hitting his own mother
to death like with that sledgehammer he
acts like it was nothing it was just
like an inanimate object that yeah like
started hitting someone who's very empty
very disconnected yeah yeah I don't
understand but the fact that she was
sleeping like she she got killed in her
sleep I don't know like she had no way
of defending herself that's what like
well really kind of upsets me I don't
know if this is [ __ ] up or not to say
but at least she was sleeping no it's
probably like he probably hit her in the
head and then she probably jolted up and
then before she knew it jolted up like
woke up or something probably gave her
like a concussion but she could still be
like oh I don't know what the [ __ ] sorry
I don't know it's scary and a little bit
scary I'm afraid to go to sleep like
what if Nick goes me well he's your
boyfriend and if someone killed you I'm
sure they have good reasoning I know a
lot about you
I am leaving your house right now hi
okay anyway guys thanks for tuning into
this little YouTube channel we have here
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects well we
cover really dark topics in
light-hearted manner and you can check
out salamander Sally's channel it's good
it's a good Channel I know I can't
impersonate this guy that's a stupid
thing to embark on it's a really good
channel I recently did a video with her
on there you should check it out and you
can follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter where if we get enough followers
we can get product placement where I do
less work make more money and you get no
benefit
I wanted to give a shout out to a Jael I
want to shout out more female subs a
Jael looking at her profile photo in
really small size and IG didn't say she
wanted to shout out but a Jael if that
is your picture you are hot enough to
the point where you don't need to ask
congratulations your looks have gotten
new places you have till at least 29
before it stops doing that for you you
know a Jay L stands for you were going
over that yeah I was trying to think of
like what I could stand for what Anil
jackoff lik ah doesn't even make sense